For the Obama family, Christmas and the New Year has always been a time...
...to reflect on our many blessings...
...to rejoice in the pleasure of spending time with our family and our friends,...
...and to renew our commitment to one another, and to the causes that we believe in.
And I wanted to continue that part of the tradition...
...during our first holiday season here at the White House,...
...which is as we always say, the people's house.
Our starting point was a very simple idea...
...that we include as many people, in as many places, in as many ways as we can.
We took about 800 ornaments leftover from previous administrations.
We sent them to 60 local community groups throughout the country...
...and asked them to decorate them to pay tribute to a favorite local landmark,...
...and then, send them back to us for display here at the White House.
Thanks to the East Wing and residence staff,...
...and 92 volunteers from 24 states...
...who spent more than 3,400 hours decorating over the last several days.
We opened the doors last night to the first of more than 50,000 visitors...
...who will come to the White House during this holiday season,...
...and it's safe to say that everyone was really impressed.
For many people, a visit to the White House is a once in a lifetime experience...
...and it has been made even more magical because of all of your hard work.
In the New Year, we all intend to renew this effort and continue this kind of outreach,...
...so that everyone feels like they have a place here at the White House.